whenever you feel sad mad nervous or out
of control write down what you're
thinking and then ask yourself if it's
true
and there's a whole process in the book
to not believe every stupid thing you
think and then when you go to say
something to your wife or
at work does it fit there's an exercise
actually in all of my books basically
called the one page miracle and one
piece of paper write down what you want
your relationships your work
your money your physical emotional
spiritual health what do you want i
think everything starts with what do you
want and then
does your behavior get you what you want
so for example with my wife i want a
kind caring loving supportive passionate
relationship i always want that i don't
always feel like that sometimes i'll get
a rude thought in my head i'm having a
bad day or she didn't do she's
not great about closing cabinet doors
and i've come to believe
i would so much rather have her in this
house with the cabinet door open than
have her not there so i like let it go
because being
a jerk
doesn't fit
the goal i have for my marriage
but it starts with telling your frontal
lobe so that's the front third of your
brain largest in humans than any other
animal by far this is what makes us
human but you have to tell it what you
want so over time you match your
behavior to get what you want so it
starts with that
and then does it fit
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that's holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn the seven
science-backed ways to heal your mind
and keep it healthy
enjoy
i love that idea of telling your brain
what you want especially if i'm talking
to an entrepreneur
they don't know what they want so they
have like a vague idea
but they don't really know the specifics
of what they want and my thing is if you
want to get somewhere if you're really
trying to accomplish something the
amount of hard work of practice of
learning that you're going to have to do
is really pretty extraordinary but if
you're not aiming that at the right
thing then you're never going to make
progress and so everything you're trying
to accomplish in your life has to be so
clear that it boils down to something
that you can do right now today
do you have a process for people for
that is it as simple as just writing it
down like how do you walk people through
the idea of getting that level of
clarity in their life so i have
virtually all of my patients
start with the one page miracle
on one piece of paper and so as we do
therapy over time
it's does it fit you know does the food
you're eating
does the thoughts you have do your
relationships
fit ultimately your purpose and
all
good businesses have plans they have
business plans and they have goals and
they have quarterly priorities and so on
but very few people ever do that
for themselves and when i first did it
in 1986 i think it just helped me so
much clarify because you know raymond
clinics and brain md are two companies
um
i didn't even imagine it back then but
it's consistent effort over a long
period of time you end up doing
something special you've written so many
books on the topic given so many talks
and the shows you've done on pbs i mean
it this is a really big topic how do you
help people that feel overwhelmed that
don't know where to start they don't
know how to keep going
how do you give them that entry point
well that's why i write
you know and that's why we have eight
clinics it's
we want to coach them
through it and people go i can't afford
to come to the clinic well get a book
you can get it at the library um there's
so much free things online because
our goal if we're really going to end
mental illness the end of mental illness
begins with a revolution in brain health
i talk about this concept if i was an
evil ruler how would i create mental
illness in america we are creating it in
america by the food we serve by the news
that is everywhere sort of the toxic pit
you against me
news cycles social media um letting kids
hit soccer balls with their head having
girl scouts girl scouts selling
poison uh
you talking about cookies eisen cookies
yeah
and
last year alone nicotine use among
teenagers went up 36 percent
so jewel
is an evil ruler strategy it's yeah i
mean they have bubble gum flavored
vaping devices that's directed at
children hello um
we need to be more thoughtful way number
two optimize your sleep with matthew
walker you wrote a book called why we
sleep and i'm always worried when i'm
bringing somebody on that's covering a
subject that i've talked about before if
they're going to hit it in a new way and
i loved your book you come at it from a
totally different angle i wore my brain
shirt out of acknowledgement of
how much you talk about sleep and the
neurological impact and so i want to
start with
two things from the book that really
blew my mind and the first is that sleep
is so
important that the guinness book of
world records will not let people try to
set records for sleep deprivation
walk us through why not i think this is
a great entry to your world
yes so what we know is that a lack of
sleep
will
impact just about every major
physiological system in your body and
almost every operation of your mind for
example if i were to take you and limit
you to just four hours of sleep for one
single night
there is almost a 70 drop in what we
call natural killer cell activity which
are critical anti-cancer fighting immune
cells that's after one night or four
hours of sleep that's crazy secondly if
i were to short sleep you for just one
week your levels of testosterone would
be that of someone 10 years your senior
define short sleep what how many hours
so here we could be talking about four
to five hours a night for four or five
nights in a row which if you look at the
data on the survey that's not unusual
for perhaps even 20 to 30 percent of the
population
certainly during the week
um we also know from daylight savings
time that it doesn't take very much
because there is a global experiment
that's performed on about 1.6 billion
people across 70 countries twice a year
and it's called daylight savings time
now in the spring when we lose one hour
of sleep we see a 24
increase in heart attacks the following
day yes in the autumn in the fall we see
a 21
decrease in heart attacks
now you collide all of that information
together as well as the impact on the
brain the mental health issues regarding
anxiety suicidality depression as well
as increased risk for alzheimer's
disease and we've been seeing that as
well
um all of these things created this
perfect storm for guinness to take a
step back they used to recognize world
record-breaking attempts and to put this
in context
you know several years ago a remarkable
individual i think his name was felix
baumgardner an austrian
um with red bull he went up in a space
capsule he went to the outer edges of
our atmosphere of our planet he opened
the door
and then in a space suit he jumped out
he hurtled back down to earth at over a
thousand kilometers per hour he broke
the sound barrier with his body
and guinness says
that's just fine however sleep
deprivation attempts no longer because
they are that much more concerning to
your mental your physical and your
cognitive health
that is the perfect
explanation like that dichotomy of felix
baumgartner versus just not getting
enough sleep and i don't think it's a
mistake that the navy seals use it just
catastrophic sleep deprivation as a part
of their hell week to really find out
like who's got the mental resilience to
make it on the other side
because when you're talking because i if
i remember right they get like
three hours of sleep over five days or
just something stupid like that
remarkably minimal and they start
hallucinating you know i had a friend
who was um he was in the british version
of that um and they were saying you know
they were running around on these hills
during sort of these combat training
events and they were just seeing sort of
gravestones popping up in front of them
they were just delusional and
hallucinating
what's going on like what is it that
causes us to hallucinate do we know the
mechanism whatever breakdown there is
between the conscious and subconscious
mind i'm not even sure what's happening
yeah what we think is happening is that
after some degree of sleep deprivation
you build up this pressure for the
different stages of sleep and one of the
two main stages of sleep of human sleep
at least is something called rapid eye
movement sleep or rem sleep which is the
stage that is principally associated
with dreaming
and what we've learned is that once you
start to go through sleep deprivation
and including rem sleep deprivation the
brain gets so starved of this thing
called dream sleep
that it just simply says look
at at some point i've got to get this
thing called rem sleep and if you're
going to stay awake i don't really care
i'm just going to produce this state of
rem sleep and so it's almost as though
you're awake but the veil of rem sleep
dreaming comes over the brain and
therefore you're essentially dreaming
while you're awake and that's why you
start seeing these hallucinations and
delusions that's our current
understanding one thing i heard you talk
about is cognitive behavioral therapy
for insomnia which i found
very interesting and i know so little
about it but knowing what i know about
cognitive behavioral therapy in terms of
pattern interrupting and things like
that are you is this like us sending a
sort of subconscious signal to our brain
like how does that work
not quite so i what we know obviously
has been the rise of sleep difficulties
in society and that has been matched by
unfortunately a rise in pharmacology and
particularly sleeping pills and i say
unfortunately not because i'm
anti-medication and i know a lot of
people who work at these pharmaceutical
companies and they're good people great
scientists wanting to do good things
but unfortunately sleeping pills are
largely blunt instruments and they don't
produce naturalistic sleep
they're in a class of drugs that we call
the sedative hypnotics
and when we take sleeping pills we
mistake sedation for sleep but it's not
natural sleep
and in fact
sleeping pills have been associated with
a significantly higher risk of death as
well as cancer
so much so that in 2016 the american
college of physicians made a landmark
recommended
intervention they said that sleeping
pills must no longer be the first line
treatment for
insomnia instead the american college of
physicians said it has to be cognitive
behavioral therapy for insomnia that
must be the first line recommended
treatment for those sleep problems
and so cognitive behavioral therapy in
general really tries to target two
things cognitive
and behavioral
and so the cognitive aspects for
insomnia
are aspects where we try to correct your
beliefs or your misbeliefs around sleep
and some of your ideas around sleep some
of those things that can be either
inappropriate incorrect or just
triggering anxiety or worry
so we try to modify those cognitions
those beliefs but then we also look at
what you're doing in your life the
different behaviors that you're doing or
things that you're not doing and try to
correct the behaviors as well for
example how's your caffeine intake how's
your alcohol intake what time are you
going to bed what time you're waking up
what's your chronotype are you a morning
type evening type are you sleeping in
harmony with your chronotype or against
your chronotype
um are you getting daylight in the
morning are you getting too much
daylight
light at night artificial light at night
do you exercise
and so we change behaviors and we change
thought patterns and together
cognitive behavioral therapy for
insomnia is just as effective as
sleeping pills in the short term but
what's great is that when you stop
working with that clinician
or your online uh program and i should
say that i um i'm i work with a company
i'm an advisor to a company called chuni
um it's s h u
n i dot i o if people want to go and
explore it and you can get cognitive
behavioral therapy online there
but you work with your therapist and
after about
five or six sessions
you can continue that benefit of
improved sleep for up to five years the
studies have demonstrated now whereas
with sleeping pills when you stop their
use
then not only do you go back to the bad
sleep that you ha you are having you
typically go back to even worse sleep
it's called rebound insomnia and now you
have to go back onto the use so you
become dependent there is an addiction
dependency cycle so that's really what
cbti is and that's really the best
approach for sleeping problems right now
all right so i have two sleeping
problems one is that there are times
where i will get
either really stressed or i'll get
really excited and i have a very easy
time falling asleep but then i'll wake
up after three or four hours and i find
it very difficult to fall back asleep
and then the second part just so i don't
forget is sleep inertia in the morning
but what can i do to um optimize for
staying asleep
yes so there it's a case of trying to
deal with that sort of downgrade the
activation of the nervous system the
reason that people typically wake up uh
in the middle of the night and can't get
back to sleep not always but often
is because they have this sort of stress
related they're carrying this anxiety
and anxiety biologically is the
principal mechanism that we think
underlies most insomnia
and what happens in part is that the
fight or flight branch of the nervous
system becomes overactive
and that's exactly why does it shut down
like i find it so easy to fall asleep
but i can tell on the nights where i'm
going to wake up
yeah it just seems weird
but then my subconscious mind kicks it
back alive yeah why why would it be that
way and the reason is because after
about 16 hours of wakefulness you've
built up a lot of that healthy
sleepiness what we call sleep pressure
and the longer that you're awake the
more of that sleep pressure builds up
and it's a chemical that builds up in
the brain called adenosine
and then when we go into sleep it's the
time when the brain can actually start
to clear out that adenosine and it's so
it starts to lower the sleep pressure
and after about eight hours of sleep
you've cleared away 16 hours of that
adenosine of that sleepiness and so you
wake up naturally and you feel refreshed
and restored
but what will happen is that you can be
stressed and sort of or excited but the
sleeping the weight of sleepiness
pulling you down is so heavy at that
point that you can get to sleep but then
three or four hours later you've
jettisoned maybe 50 percent of all of
that adenosine maybe even more because
it principally happens during deep sleep
and so now your brain is much more
vulnerable to those awakenings because
it doesn't have the weight of that
sleepiness does that make some sense it
makes total sense and it makes me want
to punch myself back to sleep way number
three master your breathing with lewis
house it's all about mastering your
breathing one of the most powerful tools
for keeping our minds in a calm state is
something we too often take for granted
our breath
if you're able to control your breath
and connect with it during times of
stress or anxiety you'll be tapping into
a super effective strategy for emotional
regulation
there are thousand different breathing
techniques out there so i encourage you
to explore them and see what works for
you but today i'm going to dive into
three specific breathing practices that
we can all use when we're feeling
anxiety starting to kick in
and i learned the first one from
stanford professor dr andrew huberman
and when he was on the show he
demonstrated what he called the
physiological psi
this technique helps bring down the
levels of carbon dioxide in our blood it
is actually the same type of breathing
that we engage in when we sleep the
pattern is a double inhale through the
nose usually a long breath
followed by a quick shorter one
and then a prolonged exhale through our
mouth now it might seem easy but the
science has shown that it really works
in fact andrew's lab found that our
carbon dioxide levels can be
significantly brought down in as little
as one two or three
physiological size this is because the
long exhale sends a signal to the heart
to slow down which helps lower anxiety
and leads us into a calmer state so
here's an example
two inhales in
and then a sigh
do that a few times and see how it feels
another method comes from one of my
friends the dutch daredevil motivational
speaker and
and crazy iceman wim hof he actually
demonstrated his famous breathing
technique to me in person a few years
back on the channel and you can watch
that full session if you want to but
this technique usually takes a few
minutes or more to do so i won't
demonstrate the entire thing for you in
this episode but i encourage you to
write it down what i'm about to tell you
and and give it a try
first you want to get into a comfortable
position either lying down or sitting
down
and be comfortable you want to clear
your mind then breathe in fully and
exhale deeply so you're gonna breathe in
and you're gonna repeat this 30 to 40
times now on the last breath of that set
you blow the air all the way out
and then you hold your breath
you hold your breath
until you need to take a breath in you
inhale through your nose until you feel
your chest fully expanded
[Applause]
and then you hold for 15 seconds
and then you start again you exhale and
then you start again and i remember i'm
already just getting sweaty just doing
it a few times i can feel it in my body
really start to activate and i remember
when i did this for the first time
feeling so at peace and relaxed after i
did it you can do this a few times
through and it'll really start to feel
throughout your entire body but you want
to make sure you're relaxed
and in a neutral position
and the third and final technique is
what's called box breathing it's called
this because you do the exercise and
counts of four to get started get an
upright position or a seated position
empty out your lungs and then slowly
inhale for four seconds so exhale your
lungs and then you inhale for four
seconds
you hold your breath for another four
seconds
and you blow out for four seconds
and you repeat the process again and
again so it's four
in four hold four out repeat the process
and similar to what the psychological
side does box breathing helps clear out
the built up carbon dioxide in our
bodies and then it puts us in a more
relaxed state so i encourage you to try
these breathing strategies if you
haven't already it really will help you
calm your mind
calm your body get into a place of peace
so you can think more clearly and let go
of the stress that you might have in
your life
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there way number four is heal your
emotional trauma with dr raul jandai the
brain has the ability to heal from
traumatic
from trauma then physical and emotional
trauma because i feel like the emotional
hidden trauma
can be more painful
and harder to recover for some the
psychological emotional trauma than the
physical trauma you can you can see it
and you can treat the physical trauma in
a sense
but depending on how intense it is but
the emotional psychological hidden
traumas i feel like
are invisible and people don't think
they need to treat it because they don't
see a broken arm and say i need to go to
the doctor because my my bone is
sticking out let me put a splint on it
and heal it up
we're not trained that way
there is no easy answer yeah but what i
will say is that um
trauma
this is just these are my concepts
they're not i'm not yes
there's therapeutic trauma and what i
mean by that is
resetting a bone after it's broken
the pain of a cancer surgery but then
you know that your cancer has been cut
out like that
that's good pain right
we're just talking about physical trauma
yes
then there's emotional trauma if when if
people are attacked that's also
intimately
connected to emotional trauma right so
the the
people who don't have memory after
certain uh injuries or operations
they never have ptsd because they don't
remember it
so the emotional context and memories
related to trauma be it emotional
physical or a combination requires
memory that's cool right i like to think
about like as a concept i don't have a
solution for
i don't hey don't do these three things
you'll be better sort of not my approach
because when people did that with me i
was like how do you know what i'm going
through man
you look at me you think everything's
good are you sure
are you sure i wasn't attacked last
night are you sure i didn't find out
that my patient didn't do well last
night are you sure i didn't find out a
loved one was diagnosed with something
you know like i just don't want to put
people in the in
in boxes in fact i want people to know
that they are new every day
i'm not even the same
version of myself i was before the last
few years how can i be understood as a a
group of people a man or a surgeon you
know i just want people to think as of
each other as individuals dynamic
that said
uh i never judge people's trauma to be
better or worse people are looking or
stronger or
justified they're looking at everybody's
going to have a traumatic event in their
life whether it's a car crash or hearing
it's unavoidable it's partly because we
put ourselves out there it's partly
because the way we approach the world is
to be completely
um adaptive
right if we're rigid
then
there's less chances for trauma but but
that's a life less well lived so when
you put yourself out there
traumatic experiences are unavoidable
right that said okay so that said yeah
you get a bruise what i'm hearing you
say is but what i'm hearing you say is
that
if we don't have the memory of the
traumatic event we don't have ptsd we
don't have trump we don't have a trauma
tail
right so that that's the
that's the concept that people that i
want people to walk away say memory is
important
memory is the thing that determines
whether the event remains traumatic and
whether it's painful still for your book
so let's get into that so we just need
to heal the memory of the trauma that's
exactly where i'm taking it um
very good
the
so
memories are not uh files in a cabinet
and actually in the brain
how is memory categorized again it's
there are some regions that we if we
remove them you would lose memory
but memory is not only there it relies
on
pulling from
memories of smell to news like for
example smell is very interesting it's
one of the five senses that we can't
tamp down with our thinking so the
perfume or cologne
smell and memory are intimately
intertwined and so you're pulling from
all different parts of the brain again
memory is a certain electrical flow in
the brain
but it's not
it's malleable
it's moldable
just because you have a certain memory
today
doesn't mean that that experience good
or bad
will remain good or bad our pop our
positive vibe right now can be made
negative our negative vibe right now can
be made positive as we look back at our
day today so when you see memory that
way then you then you say okay wait a
second
i was attacked or i was hurt or
something really traumatized me and i
think of it when i smell that
smell when i see that color
i'm
i'm traumatized again i clench up i have
like stress or fear anxiety yeah so the
emotional
the emotional context to a memory is
what you can change
you don't want to you don't want
dementia you don't want to delete the
memory because that's a different
problem yeah you don't want to block it
you don't want yeah but you what you
want to do is change the emotional
context attached to that memory what
happens if we
you hear this from people a lot who
might have been traumatized as kids
where they forget they kind of block the
memory and then
they whatever surfaces they research
it's very raw yeah but they've stuffed
it they've blocked it they've
numbed it
addicted it whatever you want to call it
driven into addiction but yeah exactly
so so what happens when i don't know i i
don't know about the the kid stuff as
much because that that's a different
space and i don't want to
you know i want to stay where i feel
real comfortable with what i've been
reading and learning
so emotional context of memory for
adults
in the right setting with the right
person through
ex you know they have their techniques
you can actually work through the trauma
of the memory and the experience by
going to certain therapists
who help you get better with that so
process the memory
yeah just to take take the emotional
pain
right the emotional trauma
and dampen that
so you can say for example yeah i was
you know i'm just bringing examples from
my world
yeah when i was i was diagnosed with
cancer
that's a traumatic event
and then you see my my patients you see
them over time through different ways
when they say they say i was you know i
was diagnosed with cancer and i did this
their face is different describing it
later than it was
immediately after receiving the
diagnosis so
that that is that's a real life example
right i'm not it doesn't have to be all
the stuff
uh
you know related to violence and all
that sure the traumatic experience of a
cancer diagnosis
and how patients cope with that
immediately
and then you see them months later years
later because i'd be a mess right i'd be
like okay this is
i wouldn't be able to cope but they
surprisingly not some of them
most of them cope they get dressed they
come in
for their three-month scans which to me
would be a traumatic experience every
time is this guy going to tell me it's
back or it's bigger i mean think about
like getting that nothing in your mail
or email i got to go in for this
scary muse again yeah but somehow they
cope and that's where in in life on a
nice edge i learned so much from them
that it's possible
to cope with traumatic experiences i'm
not saying you as an individual can i'm
not saying i can but when you look at a
group of cancer patients and most of
them wow
cope
live move on from very traumatic
emotional experiences as well as
physical experience of cancer pain and
cancer surgery right that's the lesson i
want everybody to go through
um in their mind when they're dealing
with their own challenges wow way number
five meditate with robert greene i know
recently you had a stroke and the way
that you're approaching it has the sort
of milton erickson written all over it
with rebuilding yourself but with a
writer's mind and so you're paying
attention to what it takes and what
you're going through walk us through
that like what are you learning about
that what principles of the book are you
applying to it
well um you know so if i talk in the
book about overcoming your own nature
this damn man that was slammed into my
face
right i had to overcome my frustration
my lack of patience my willfulness the
fact that i always have to do things
myself
you know and then i had to confront the
fact that i could easily have died but i
didn't i'm alive so i can learn from
this i'm learning a lot
and i'm going to rebuild my body i'm
going to rebuild it i've come a long way
so like a month ago i was pretty bad i'm
able to walk now fairly well
in four months from now i'm going to be
swimming again in six months i'm going
to be jogging i'm going to be back to
where i was nothing will stop me but i
have to overcome all of my deficiencies
and all of these weaknesses that i have
built up over the years
yeah that is needless to say that's a
long difficult road um
how do you
or what tools do you use to reset your
mind every day as you're going through
this in in paralleling that maybe to
that check off story in the book and how
what he overcame and was really
extraordinary being beaten by his father
all the time
and that he goes on to be the guy that
isn't bitter was pretty extraordinary
what mechanisms do you use to reset
every day i meditate every morning i've
been doing that for several years for
eight years now religiously
and in those meditations i confront
myself
so
i'm sitting there meditating and my
meditation is all about emptying the
mind but it's impossible to empty the
mind so as you're meditating thoughts
come to you anxieties worries
resentments
i've trained myself to question where
they are
each time i feel anger at my
sibling or my mother or friend for
saying something that i misinterpreted i
go
that's your ego speaking you these
people weren't saying something that was
personal you just have your ego which is
always getting in your way question it
so question my impatience my
frustrations etc the meditation has
really helped me way number six build a
tougher mindset with dean graziosi life
can pull us in a lot of directions the
craziness of the outside world can allow
us to forget about our dreams or find
imposter syndrome or lose our confidence
lose our drive lose our desire lose our
focus we get overwhelmed on not knowing
where to start and then we don't start
at all all those things happen their
life
add in two and a half years of covid
now at that we're going into an economic
winter and inflation high which is gas
and food and all the prices are high we
add that we're in a polarized time in
history where it feels like everybody's
trying to push us apart when we're
trying to come back together anybody
feel that way wouldn't we rather all
just get together and find our common
ground the media and the world want to
tell us how different we are but i think
we have way more in common
than everybody's telling us and if we
all were exactly the same wouldn't that
just be a boring world right
so we're in this time of
a couple of two and a half years of of
of covid and then we go into a place
where there's now we're in an economic
downturn
um recession
looming i think by july one they'll
officially announce we're in a recession
if you ask somebody we're actually in it
and i was in business for myself in 2009
or in
2007 when we went to a recession but i
was also in business for myself in 1999
who remembers the the internet crash
right of 99 i was in business then as
well naive and didn't even know it was a
thing by 2007 i understood it more and
had smarter friends and we made
transitions and shifts in advance so we
were able to thrive through that
shifting time if i was just starting in
business if i wanted to shift my life
my income my success my happiness my joy
what would i like to learn
so that's really i'd love to say that
there's more thought to it than that we
need this connection we need to be
plugged in we need not to forget what
our dreams are we need not to let
imposter syndrome
be in control of us we can't let the
inner self doubt say play small
especially now with the world shifting i
just want to tell you
this is not a time to
sit on your hands
i did an interview uh
two or three days ago with tom bilyeu i
don't know if anybody any of you have
ever seen
impact theory with tom bilyeu on youtube
he's really good dear friend he's great
he interviews wonderful people he's
really smart so i took my kids with me i
had a couple podcasts i went and saw my
friend brennan burchard and then i flew
down to go see tom bilyeu and i brought
my older kids my 13 and 15 year old and
let them see what what their dad does
i'll tell you a story about that in a
minute
um
and as i'm as i was talking with tom
and talking about where the world is
going and the shifts happening i'm going
to use the real estate space as an
example when the economy shifts
interest rates went up 0.75 all of these
things affect and and if you're old
enough to understand there's a bigger
by-product coming right the housing
industry there's no way it can't be
affected it's coming right
but when you're in an industry that's
been booming for 10 or 12 years and if
you're in the mortgage industry or the
housing if you sell houses if you build
houses if you build a part like if
you're in it
the last thing you want to do is it face
it go no maybe it's a little hiccup oh
this'll happen quick right and we get a
little amnesia up to the way it used to
be so instead of saying no no it's going
to be fine
if i truly care about you guys what i
want to do today is help prepare you
help anticipate not make it worse than
it is but not make it better than it is
you know when things change
when it's scary when something new
happens
what does we always talk about we flight
or fight right we got the flight or
fight mechanism
tom bill you said something i never
heard he said the third f
he thinks is
even more relevant in today's world and
that's freeze
that's freeze that's what i want you to
think about today that was my notes here
my team puts together nice cheat sheets
for me and i write all over them so much
and so sloppy i can't read my own
writing but what i wrote was the three
fs fight flight or freeze
with all the crap that's led up to this
recession this inflation of two and a
half years of covid where covet did
things like made us realize screw that
job of me going in every day
and not being with my family not doing
something i love being unsure missing
like screw that i'm out on that 82
percent of people right now want to quit
or leave their job to do something new
or do their own thing
never before has it been the worst it
was ever prior to this was 48
and that was a couple decades ago so 82
percent of people are like covid made me
realize maybe you went through a little
hardship but with that shift
comes uncertainty right and then all of
a sudden you slam into gas the highest
it was and inflation and now you're like
should i not buy my house should i wait
to buy should i wait to sell should i
what should i do should i invest should
i take my money out of the stock market
is my 401k gonna go away forever should
i go back today take it out and sit in
cash but if i do that they say cash is
trash so if i sit on cash it's trash but
if i leave it in the market it goes down
ah
right and all of a sudden this
uncertainty builds and if uncertainty
builds more than i've seen in my 53
years on this planet
guess what happens
freeze
i don't know if i should do my
self-education industry i don't know if
i should
do anything with investment i don't know
and when you when you feel that way you
freeze you sit on your hands you do
nothing this is not a time to freeze in
fact this is a time
to thrive
this is a time to gain capabilities
because most people are going to freeze
more than you know when we're not there
yet
if people smarter than me where we're
going with i get the chance to have
great conversations
more and more uncertainty will climb
confidence will go down and more and
more freezing will happen
so if everybody's standing around frozen
what happens if you're the one that can
build a tougher mindset that you can
anticipate this you can prepare this you
can actually get momentum you can you
this is your time to grow in 2007 8 and
9
when the world crashed and i know i've
shared this with you guys before when
the world crashed
my real estate education self-education
industry
grew faster than ever before and i ended
up owning the whole industry going into
07 i was one of about seven in my space
that were big by 2009 i was the only one
left and our company my brand had got to
almost a hundred million dollars a year
we were doing almost two million dollars
a week in sales by 2009 2010 we grew
like this because the world needed us
and i wasn't selling how to get rich at
that time i was telling people how to
how to secure themselves and be safe and
do a deal or two every other month to
make enough to get by i said if there's
other people out there could tell you
how to get rich for doing nothing or
rich overnight then maybe you should try
them because that's not me and that
message resonated and we grew like crazy
i believe this is not i what i hope to
do today is to reframe your mind to
really know
things are going to get tough for a lot
of people but this is your time to
exponentially grow this is your time to
step in the next level leader that you
have living inside of you this is your
time to crush that self-doubt even more
crush it harder stronger than you ever
did before this is your time to get rid
of the old stories and craft a new one
this is your time to realize that most
people around you are going to freeze or
run or go backwards and you have to be
that leader to be the example for your
family be example for your friends help
those that need help and when you start
looking through that lens when we change
that mind we could say
i'm sorry it's coming
but bring it way number seven eat for
your brain with j shetty in this video
i'm going to walk you through the five
things i consume daily to keep my mind
and body healthy a lot of habits and
techniques that are healthy for us take
some time to develop but if you're one
of those people who's sitting there
going jay i don't have time to learn how
to do something new jay i don't have the
space to add anything to my life or my
calendar then the tips in this video are
going to make a difference in your life
the first thing i consume at the
beginning of the day is a cup of tea
i find that tea has this unique ability
to start your day with stillness there
are so many benefits to having a cup of
tea in the morning stress alleviation
immune system support and detoxifying it
all starts with the process of heating
up the water now i'm old school i don't
use a kettle i was always taught to heat
up my water like this on a stove and for
me this is where the mindful process
begins from filling it up to watching
the water to watching it heat up once
the tea is poured i take a moment to
inhale the scent this is such a mindful
and meditative practice if you're
someone that struggles with being in the
moment or meditating this is a great way
to start
start by looking at the color of the tea
then by inhaling and taking in the
beautiful scent
and then taking a sip i promise you it's
an experiment in presence and you'll be
so engaged and so involved that you'll
recognize what it feels like to live in
the now this is one of my favorite ways
to start the day because my mind is at
ease
it's calm it's peaceful and at the same
time my body feels like it's getting
this warm hug and that i'm feeling the
energy all across my body
one of the things i really struggled
with for many years was bloating in the
morning i found that no matter what i
ate whatever mixture or choice i made
left me feeling heavy and bloated my
health coach mona sharma recently put me
on chia seed pudding now i didn't know
what to expect in the beginning and it
has made such a huge difference in my
life
not only is it tasty and light in the
morning i don't feel bloated at all
anymore and it's worked wonders for me
chia seed pudding provides high quality
protein and it lowers the risk of heart
disease by reducing blood sugar levels
studies show that chia seeds have a high
amount of fiber which slows the
absorption of sugar in the blood and can
decrease blood sugar levels recently i
learned that chia pudding is also great
for bone health so all around it's been
a great replacement to the usual oatmeal
or porridge or cereals that i would have
in the morning that were high in sugar
one of the other challenges i had for a
long time was that after my workout i
felt so dehydrated and so tired i would
have to get on with my work day but i'd
often resort to feeling lethargic or
lazy and i tried for a long time to
figure out why that was this changed
recently when i started using element
not only is it one of my favorite things
to drink i end up feeling so energized
and so rehydrated every single time i
usually put a packet of it into a glass
of water after my workout and the
electrolytes make a huge difference to
my energy as i said i used to struggle
with feeling lazy or lethargic after an
intense workout now i feel rejuvenated
and nourished and can take on the
challenges for the day element has had a
huge impact on my focus levels and
energy levels and i carry them around
wherever i go element has been shown to
regulate blood pressure improve energy
levels and it helps muscles contract
including your heart for a limited time
my community and followers will be able
to claim a free element sample pack and
you only have to cover the cost of
shipping five dollars for u.s customers
go to drink lmnt dot com forward slash j
now i'm being really open and honest
with you about the changes i've had to
make because of how i feel if any of you
have high inflammation you've had
indigestion you've had acid reflux i
struggled with many of those things for
quite a while and again i tried a lot of
things finally i discovered celery juice
this really got added into my routine in
january 2020 so i've been doing it for
about 18 months now and i promise you it
has changed how i feel it's removed that
inflammation it's removed that negative
acidity and now i'm able to just feel so
much more clean and fresh every time i
finish having some celery juice i almost
feel like my insides have had a shower
celery juice has been known to reduce
inflammation boost hydration and provide
beneficial antioxidants you can make it
at home if you're someone who feels
comfortable in the kitchen or you can
pick it up at a store either way it's
had a big impact on my health and i
think it will on yours too usually by
mid-afternoon i start to feel a little
bit of slump maybe i'm feeling a little
bit tired and i found that i've tried a
lot of snacks to get that energy boost
back and sometimes they're full of
sugars sometimes you're getting that
high but then that dip but one of the
ones that has really helped is plain old
nuts and now since i was a young man my
mom told me and i believe this is a old
indian tradition that if i ate five
almonds a day i'd have a really good
memory now i'm really grateful to have a
really really good memory and so of
course my mom takes all the credit for
feeding me five almonds a day and i also
added two walnuts per day now if you
look at a walnut shaped like a brain and
i was told since i was a kid that if you
eat walnuts it would be good for your
brain health as well so for me five
almonds a day and two walnuts have been
huge i've also been recently adding
brazil nuts i found that nuts are a
fantastic way of finding that energy
boost but still staying healthy walnuts
and almonds are super plant source of
omega-3 they promote healthy gut and
improve blood fats i really hope that
you're going to experiment with some of
these ideas to hopefully help you feel
better throughout the day whether it's
finding more energy reducing stress and
inflammation or whether it's just about
feeling better at the beginning of the
day now i use the word experiment
because that's what you have to do what
works for me may not work for you what
works for you may not work for me but
the idea is that i'm hoping to share
insights that will give you an
opportunity to try out something new to
try out really simple habit changes that
can have a big impact on your body and
on your mind
you mentioned that you can do 14
different activities at a given moment
so
we all are very curious to know how can
we achieve such progress over both body
and mind
oh
whoever said this i didn't say anything
like that anyway
do you have a liver
yes i do functioning
yes
do you know how many levels of activity
it's doing right now
what the liver is doing is far more
complex than what your brains are doing
right now do you know this
a brainless liver if it can do so many
things
a brand rene how many things
no i was only talking about
not activity per se
yes activity is also possible
so you must understand this
on a round planet which is spinning
right now
hello
are you on a round planet
spinning
most people don't understand this
unless uh you know they get sizzled out
with something
or they get some ailment
suddenly you see planet is round
do you know
how complex an activity it is
for a human being
to walk at a certain latitude on a round
planet which is spinning and which has
magnetic forces working upon you all the
time
it's an extremely complex process
you ask a child
who is let's say one year of age she
knows how complex it is
have you seen
but the moment you learn to walk
you assume
that it's nothing walking is nothing and
you're sick of walking you want to drive
a car you want to ride a motorcycle
but walking is such a complex process
not 14
a thousand different functions your
knees and your brains and the fluids in
your body all of them are doing all the
time
if only you could conduct these things
consciously you would be doing a
thousand things anyway you're doing it
but if you could conduct this
consciously you do a thousand things at
a time so i was only talking about
different channels of mine
which you don't have to actually conduct
you just have to initiate and leave
it will go on
for you to think about your neighborhood
goal do you have to initiate action
every time
no
once you look at her it just goes on by
itself why because you're drawn to it
if you're drawn to 10 different things
at the same time
mind is capable of creating 10 different
channels
and keep it running
a complex mathematical problem a
sensation a music some raga there's that
hundred things at the same time because
that is how complex human mind is
this complexity you can use either to
drive yourself crazy with
unbridled thought and emotion or if you
harness it it can do things that nobody
has imagined possible
it can do things
in a miraculous way you can manifest
things in a phenomenal way if the
necessary training goes if somebody is
walking there if you just look at them
how they are walking you can make out
whether they're physically fit or not
yes or no
body has been worked upon you can see it
or not just by the walk
similarly whether the mind has been
worked upon or not whether your energies
have been worked upon or not
is something that's visible most people
may not see but if you pay attention you
will see
right now
most human beings the problem is we gave
you a super super super computer
the most sophisticated
machine on this planet is this human
mechanism i am asking you have you read
the user's manual
hello
no
when you're going to read it on the last
day
when i see this ridiculous stuff people
reading gita when people are dying
i say you're reading the user's manual
on the last day what's the point
if you buy a phone
should you read the user's manual in the
first three days or after three years
when you want to get rid of the phone
you must read it in the first three days
so i am not asking you to read a
scripture
well this is a living scripture
should you not become competent to read
the scripture
understand what is the nature of this
what is the full potential of it and
explore this because this life is not
about this or that this life is about
this
there is no choice about this
it is just that you can enslave this
life to something else and think it's
about that
but actually it's about this are you
okay with this
you think right now your life is about
education no your life is about this
you want this one educated
you want this one to do well you want
this one to experience love you want
this one to experience pleasure you want
this one to
do all this
all the other things are only
attendant things this is the real thing
isn't it
so if this is the real thing
he does this deserves some amount of
attention
some amount of attention means not
standing in front of the mirror and
attending to your skin endlessly
should you not pay attention to every
dimension of what this human being is
made of
what makes this life tick
and how if you understand what makes it
tick you can make it raw
if you make it raw why 14 things you can
do many more 80 percent of our inner
dialogue
is negative
and 95
of those thoughts are the same thoughts
that we had yesterday that's what beth
handel taught me she's gary vee's life
coach we had an awesome session together
and it really hit home imagine that 80
of the thoughts that you've got
80
are negative
we are beating ourselves up we're
telling ourselves that we can't do
things it's not even our friends and
family people around us telling us that
we suck it's us it's ourselves we tell
ourselves we're not good enough we can't
do this we're not strong enough smart
enough we're from the wrong country we
look the wrong way you know we're too
young we're too old whatever it is 80 of
our thoughts are negative and then 95 of
those negative thoughts are the exact
same negative thoughts that we had
yesterday it's no wonder why we stay
small it's no wonder why we stay stuck
because we've created this reinforcing
loop of negativity this is why i think
the world's biggest problem is lack of
belief i'm on a mission every day wake
up trying to make content try to spread
the message to help people believe in
themselves more i think lack of belief
is the single biggest problem in the
world
and i also believe that everybody has
michael jordan level genius at something
like you are the greatest you're the
greatest in the world at something and
it's not what you went to school for and
it's not what your parents did for a
living probably it's something
completely different and you have to
have the courage to go off and chase it
and find it and and do it because
the woman who solves cancer
should have already solved it by now but
she never believed in herself enough to
go to medical school and now she's a
manager and accounting firm which isn't
like her life right i mean this is this
is where most of us are stuck most
people wake up and they drive the job
that that we don't like most people are
stuck and barely hanging on
and do not like their life and feel like
they're not contributing they're not
they're not making any kind of
difference they're not doing anything
meaningful or impactful at all in the
world that's most people like imagine
waking up and that's your daily reality
that may be you
or that may have been who you were
you're still discovering and trying to
improve and get better but if 80 of
those thoughts that come through your
head conscious or unconscious are
negative i think a lot of conscious
thoughts are negative too
not just the subconscious the conscious
thoughts are negative
you're telling yourself that you can't
do something and you're not good enough
and then 95
are the same as yesterday that we've
just created this
this loop this negative
thinking loop
so how do we break it how do we break
free how do we solve that problem well
that's that's the billion dollar
question and that's what i wake up
every day trying to fix and i can give
you a couple things that i've worked on
that i found helpful and hopefully helps
move the needle they don't have all the
answers but but some of these might help
the first one is to change your
environment the environment makes such a
huge difference for who you are and your
daily habits and what you believe about
yourself and the environment is not just
the people who are around you although
that definitely helps you know if you've
got negative friends or family around
you you want to eliminate them
completely or spend a lot less time with
them because
it's really really really hard to have a
beautiful plant grow when it's just you
know toxic waste being poured on top of
them doable but really really really
difficult and so changing that can
really help and
one of the best ways i found to do it is
content
it's content it's why i make so much
content for these channels that
hopefully
you wake up today and there's a piece of
content there waiting for you whether
it's
me or showcasing somebody else across
all my channels we're making multiple
pieces content every single day to try
to hit it in the right way maybe today's
message with the right voice is the one
that makes a difference for you and if
you can shift
the amount of entertainment you're doing
or just uh shutting off the world some
of the content that you consume just
helps you shut off the world and escape
versus educational content that helps
you learn improve get better and solve
the problem right entertainment is let's
forget about the problem just laugh at
something else
education is let's learn and to actually
fix the problem that is happening in our
life right i want to lean in on that a
lot more it doesn't mean entertainment
doesn't exist
in your life it's not only education but
if you can shift the needle towards
education to be around the people who
inspire you even if you've never met
them
it can really move the needle for your
your inner dialogue and your
self-confidence so the thing that saved
me in my first business in doing this
was modeling
uh bill gates from microsoft when i i
quit on my business partner i struggled
i didn't know
you know i felt worthless nothing was
working i was working every day and just
no results in in looking at bill gates
story that that
changed my life it saved my business it
allowed me to keep going because now i
had a little bit of hope that hmm bill
gates could do it maybe i could too and
the more you surround yourself with
those people the more you'll feel like
you can do it too so do an audit how
many people in your life the
the
actual humans that you know and also
just the people that you subscribe to
that you follow how many of them make
you feel better about yourself and for
too many people it's it's not enough you
know it's it's
look at who you follow on youtube look
at who you subscribed to
um look at who you're connecting with on
instagram you know if you're loading
your phone you're going through
instagram or you're watching youtube
videos how many times have you gone
through it and all of a sudden an hour
has gone by and you were mindlessly
watching videos or even worse made you
feel worse about yourself you ever felt
that you watch a video and then you feel
worse about yourself afterwards or
you're following somebody and it makes
you feel worse about yourself you have a
choice to unfollow those people this is
not
instagram's fall to youtube's fault you
can take accountability here you have a
choice to unfollow those people and then
a choice to follow the people who make
you feel better about yourself
that's my aim with all these videos i
want to leave you with strategies but
also more belief in yourself at the end
of every video and if i do that awesome
you want more belief in your life come
back you know another shot of espresso
tomorrow morning we're here and if i
don't do that
cool thank you for giving it a shot and
and don't quit on that go find somebody
else who gives you the motivation
inspiration that you need
and so you can make a conscious choice
because it's so easy to stay stuck it's
so easy to stay small it's so easy to
to be the one that pours into other
people and not have anybody pour into us
and you need to make a conscious choice
to to raise your environment to change
your environment and it doesn't mean you
have to go move to a different country
or move to a fancier house or anything
else you start by just changing who you
associate with even
at a mass scale right
i've learned a lot from steve jobs
i've been inspired by oprah winfrey
my favorite entrepreneur of all time is
ap giannini who started bank of america
these are people who i've never met
you know and and uh in the case of jobs
in gennini i never you know will meet
because they passed
but i've been inspired by them and
they've made me better and they've
taught me and i've learned from them and
they've inspired me and i get courage
from them
because i've consumed their content
and you can do that too
it's just being intentional about it so
that when you raise your environment you
raise your life
the second thing is try not to do it
alone
it's really hard to go after
a goal to change your mindset to
accomplish big things when you're doing
it all by yourself you know
it this is why a lot of people quit
because you might have one
one amazing day or you watch the right
video you have the right experience and
it's like that i want this is
this is the life i want you ever had
that right like this is the life that i
want this is who i want to be this is
this is where i could go you have a
glimpse of a potential future that you
could be it's like i want that and and
you actually feel in your heart that you
can be that you can accomplish that
right has that happen to you
and then what happens the next day you
wake up and it's kind of gone and then
the next day it's completely gone and
then you're back to your old life and
the limiting beliefs and the habits and
and you know you gain back to 20 pounds
and like how did i end up back here i
thought i fixed this right has that ever
happened to you
a lot of it is because you're doing it
alone
and this took me a long time to figure
out
as an introverted person as a shy person
as somebody who doesn't like asking for
help
as someone who's afraid of disappointing
people
being a part of a community
is not
it just sounds super scary to me
we just did our seven day challenge for
built to serve and a bunch of people
joined movement makers uh we had almost
100 people join movement makers at the
end of it and it's people who want to be
thought leaders and want to be speakers
and authors and coaches and
course creators and membership creators
and all of this stuff there's a big
impact that spread your message and i
was giving people
a lot of uh
not just encouragement but respect like
the people who ended up joining
i just had incredible respect for
because i wouldn't have done it
if i go back to 19 year old evan when i
started my first business
i wouldn't have done it i wouldn't have
had the courage to do it i wouldn't have
joined the group
we had people sharing their videos like
tell us about your your who your why
your house your
methodology from the book but make a
video you know sharing your purpose and
your biggest pain of all time and some
of these you know kind of deep things
that you have to record and share
and
i mean it was optional not everybody did
it but
in doing that
for a lot of people was their first
video that they've ever
done for a lot of people was the first
time they've even shared their story to
anybody that they were sharing things in
the group that they hadn't told their
spouse
you know or their family or their best
friend
and now they're making a video
in their car
sharing their story
and you see them become liberated you
see them you see them start super scared
and afraid and unsure and fixing their
hair and you know apologizing for the
lighting not being good and them being
in the car and not knowing what they're
doing
to then just seeing the transformation
of somebody
going through the cocoon you know being
a
caterpillar and turned into a butterfly
and sharing their story for the first
time and i was in awe because i
i couldn't imagine me doing that at 19
when i started my first business
[Music]
i was too afraid to join a community i
was too afraid of being judged
i was too afraid of being not good
enough
and that kept me small
i kept my growth really slow
fortunately i kept going you know if
you've seen my my
my chart on my website where i show how
much i've grown every year over a year
over year over year where i've been
took five years to get the 7000
subscribers or something like that
and i just kept going and the one thing
that i've got was just tenacity and
drive and i will just keep going in the
face of adversity
but i made it just incredibly hard on
myself being alone
not being open to sharing with my
friends what i was struggling with
and never joining the community
so i think that can really help you
you know i think i think trying to go
and change your mindset and accomplish
big things that nobody around you has
done yet and there are some days that
you feel incredibly inspired and
motivated and powerful like yeah i can
do this
but you're probably not living there
most of the time
what if you did
or what if you live
kind of close to that most of the time
and
point number one of raising your
environment can definitely help
but point number two is just don't try
to do it alone
even if it's
one person you don't have to join
movement makers you don't have to join a
group
but even just one person
one person who you can talk to you can
connect with
whom
you can you know share your stories with
not just complain to not not
talk about how hard everything is and
just have somebody to vent to but
somebody who supports you
if you had a group of people who
supported you
well you felt welcome we felt like you
weren't alone on this journey we felt
like people understood you
and we're actually genuinely cheering
you on to go
you know become the person that you want
to be
everything changes
so raise your environment
get a community
and watch your impact happen
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to see 10
amazing rules from raul john die i'll
check the video right there next to me i
think you'll love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there the way i think
habits function this is these are my
ideas is that because it's such an
energy hog it wants to be efficient so
this whole myth about you only use 20 of
your brain no we use 100 our brain and
pictures show that but to get